schools across the u.s are struggling to
stay open while most are offering
in-person instruction more than 4 400
k-12 schools shifted to remote learning
or closed for at least one day last week
mainly due to covid19 related staffing
issues what happens then is the school
says okay well let's let's find a
substitute for the teacher who isn't
there but the problem is that that has
also created a shortage among
substitutes to help with the school
staffing crunch some states are stepping
in the greatest need right now today is
substitute teachers dr kurt steinhaus is
among the new mexico state officials who
spearheaded the supporting teachers and
families initiative which asks state
workers and national guard members to
volunteer to become licensed as
substitute teachers these national guard
members are community members their
coaches their parents they know
their communities
since winter break around 60 school
districts and charter schools in new
mexico have moved into remote learning
dr steinhaus said the state is short
more than a thousand substitutes less
than a week after the program was
announced 46 national guard members were
already deployed to schools these
national guard members who are
substituting they're not just in there
just randomly doing something they're
following the classroom teachers lesson
plan other states have taken similar
steps
oklahoma governor kevin stitt signed an
executive order last tuesday allowing
state workers to retain their regular
jobs while working in the classroom
since then more than 200 state employees
have signed up to become substitute
teachers they'll be able to step in with
assistance from the schools and be able
to continue that learning process in
california governor gavin newsom signed
an order aimed at reducing the barriers
for districts to hire short-term
substitute teachers we just did an
executive order this week to allow
flexibility with substitutes and
continue to allow retirees to come back
to help us with staffing shortages in
the immediate to get through the next
few weeks because we must keep our kids
in person safely in school connecticut
has also cleared a path for retired
teachers to fill in by allowing them to
work without losing retirement benefits
the kansas state board of education
temporarily eased requirements for
getting an emergency substitute license
and in late december michigan governor
gretchen whitmer signed a bill to allow
school secretaries and other staff to
work as substitutes while it's great to
find a substitute for a teacher who's
not there the ideal scenario is for the
teacher him or herself to be there as
elected officials and school
administrators push to continue
in-person learning many acknowledge that
relying on substitute teachers is not
the perfect solution substitute teachers
perform a valuable role but the fact of
the matter is they are not the classroom
teacher who knows the kids and knows
where they are with the material you
should automatically know that that
equals
five the staff shortages at both the
teacher and the sub level i think the
combination is
is raising some fresh concerns about
kids maybe falling behind in their
education at a time when there is
already widespread agreement that remote
learning was bad for a lot of kids when
it comes to the academics while the
statewide top-down approaches are
intended to address the immediate need
for teachers it will take time before
schools get back to pre-pandemic
staffing levels even as covid19 cases
decline in some parts of the country
there's no sense of mission accomplished
where we're in the clear but there is
this sense that we can get back to
something that
more resembles normal which they want
for their kids who have had anything but
that for
almost two years now